Can you please tell us a little bit more
about where you come from
And maybe a little bit about the Movement for Democratic Change here in Zimbabwe.
Thank you so much, it's a great pleasure to be here
My name is Douglas Mwonzora, I am the Secretary General of the Movement for Democratic Change.
which is the main opposition party in Zimbabwe, and is hoping to form the next government.
I am a lawyer by profession
I studied Law at the university of Zimbabwe
I joined politics in 1988, fighting against
the one-party state in Zimbabwe
I joined quite a couple of different parties
for purposes, as a young person
to fight against the one-party state, the dictatorship.
As a result of my fight against the one-party state
I've been arrested and contained by the
authorities for 34 times.
Thank God I'm still alive and here to tell the story
I was lucky enough to be appointed the [?] person
of the constitution making.
by the prime minister then, Morgan Tsvangirai,
the president of my party
It is an honour to be asked to write
a constitution for your country
When we were doing that project
my eyes were opened: it was not what I want
that matters to everyone
As human beings we must be able to accommodate others
There are other interest groups
And when you are making a constitution, it's best called a 'concordance for discordant forces in society'.
The most important thing for a constitution-maker,
is to put yourself out of the equation.
And look at the best view of society
and the various interest groups that are there.
Knowing that each interest is as important to
the person who holds it
as your interest in something else.
Unfortunately after the forging of the new constitution – which was successful –
before the crafting of the new constitution
the finishing of the constitution
it was taken to a referendum
which was a yes or no vote. Whether the people of Zimbabwe were going to say 'yes' to the constitution
Historically Zimbabwe has always voted 'no'
in a referendum
and everybody thought it would be a question of deja vu
If the Zimbabweans were going to vote 'yes',
we were going to make history.
And counting down to the referendum,
my colleagues and I were affraid that
history would repeat itself.
Fortunately for us, Zimbabweans voted 95%
for the constitution.
And we became the first group of people to do something that went to a referendum
of which the result was positive.
It was a very humbling experience indeed.
Regrettably, I lost my seat
in the elections of 2013
Ever since I've been in the opposition
I was from an ordinary member of the party
to being the spokesperson of the party, in 2011
three years later, I was elected
Secretary General of the movement
Right now, I've not gone back to teaching,
I'm running a small private practise
called 'Mwonzora and Associates', were I've got five partners in the law firm.